それでは私の今日の話に入ります
ブッダが語る女性とは男性とはというタイトルですね
性別平等論と区別論は両立できるかということで
このタイトルはね 結構前から
もうかなり前から決めてあって
ちょっと宣伝もされてあって
あまりにも宣伝しすぎちゃったなと思いますね
あまり興味がないみたいしね
で それでまあいろんなところでまあまあ
ちょろちょろと私が他の質問なんかに答える時は
まあ女性と男性っていうのはどういうものかということは
まあちょこちょことまあ言ってしまったんですね
あ これまずいと思ったんです
なぜかというと 一回言ったことは二回言わないというどうしようもない性格なんです
だから今日はいろんなところで言った大事なポイントは全部抜けました
で 今日は今日だけの話にしようかなと
しかし 皆様の心の中でもいくらかイメージができていると思いますね
まあ男女は平等だろう
あれやこれやとかね 言うだろうと言います
で 全く違うことになると思います
まずはまあちょっと触れます
世間が大騒ぎするこの問題に対して
仏教には興味ありません
男女は平等かどうかとかね
そんなの仏教に全然興味ないんです
世界で宗教が女性を差別してきたんです
世界の人間が女性を差別してきたんですよ
それから世界の宗教 どんな宗教の人であっても
女性を差別するんですね
世界が変わって 社会における女性の立場も変わっていくと
突然 男女平等という言葉が現れるんです
だから世界がもうアホなことをやったんだからって
なんで仏教はそれに弁解しなくちゃいけないんですかね
お釈迦様が生命という立場で喋ってるんです
スッタニパータのワーセタスッタという経典がありまして
お釈迦様は人間が一緒一緒だと
ものすごいもう もう何て言いますか
力を強く語っているんです
人間である だからブッダの言葉だからみんなブッダの言葉でしょ
誰が気にするもんかいということにも置いておくだけでね
だから私はどちらかといえば怒るべきなんですね
で それほど現代的で立派なことを語っている
唯一の人類についてね
必要なことを語っているのに
へっちゃらで無視する
ですから 仏教はいかがでしょうかと
男女平等だと思っているのかと
だからと言われると いい加減にしなさいという言葉しか言わなくなっちゃいますね
仏教ははじめから人間っていうのは一つの生物学的にバイオロジーという立場から見れば一種類なんですね
まあニグロ人とか白人とかいろいろ
なんか分けてますけど
それでも生物学的には人間というのは一種類なんですね
そこで女性蔑視するっていうのはね
いかに原始的かっていうことなんです
で 他宗教はどういうふうに女性について語っているのかということは
全部データをね 出しますと思っていたんです
で それもまだやめた 時間の関係もあるし
人の悪口を言うのはやめましょうと
とにかくいろいろ宗教は名前は今日は言いませんだけど
女性っていうのはただ男の所有物
あの財産なんですね 財産が 2種類あります
あの動くものと動かないものという言葉使ってますけどね
そういう家畜動物と同じ
まあ生きてる財産なんですね
だからそこをよくわきまえてくださいというふうなことで
女性たちにいろいろ厳しい戒律やら仕来りやら
使ってるんですね 女性は家畜動物だから外に出るなよと
体隠しておけと そこまで言ってるんです
で 仏教にはそういうのは関係ないんです
社会で宗教が犯した罪を自分たちで償うべきなんです
だから それはまあ 世の中の人々は自分たちが犯した罪をね
何とかしてくださいと
で 仏教の課題は衆生とは？生命とは何？なんです
仏教ははじめからも生命とは何なのかと
男って何？女って何ってのは関係ない
考えたこともない 生命とは何だ？ってね
仏教のテーマなんですね
で 葉一枚を見て森を理解するというね
それはありえないということなんです
仏教は一切衆生 サッベーサッターの本質について語るんです
仏教を学ぶと 皆様が気に入るか気に入らなかろうか
それは関係なく 仏教は生命について話しているんですね
生命というか 犬も猫もミミズもみんな入ります
世界は白人論 黒人論 西洋人論
アジア人論 男女論 人間優越論などで争っているんですね
例えば もうすぐ最近まで人間がすごく唯一で存在だと
地球上で堂々と言っていたんですよ
その理由は まあまあ聖書にあるインチキ話なんですね
で すべての生命を支配するために人間を作ったという
よくもそれ信じるんですね
信じて人間が優れているんだと
私はいくらでも証拠を出せますよ
人間そう思うほど優れていないんだということを
ただ違うところといえば
言語を使っているだけのことで
それもむちゃくちゃバラバラで
言語を使ってもはっきり気持ちは通じないんですね
で 猫も言語使ってますよ
猫語わかる方います？いないね
で 猫語を皆様に聞くのたった一つニャンだけなんですけど
よく聞いてください それ
いろいろイントネーションがあるんですね
それからニャンの長さもそれぞれ微妙に違う
それからキーがそれぞれ違いますね
それによってしっかりと猫同士で会話していますね
誤解はまずないんです
カラスも同じなんですね
カーッと鳴くだけだと思ってるでしょ？そうじゃないんです
それなりの必要なものを相手に伝えるぐらいの言葉持ってます
それで誤解が起きませんよ
だったら言語として立派ですよ
我々は言語を使ってますけど
相当誤解が起こるんですね
例えば まあことわざっぽい単語たくさんあるでしょう
それがもしかすると理解していないかもしれません
例えば英語で言えば Go to hell という言葉がありますね
これはあまり使っていけないという一部の人々もいますけど
しかし  Go to hell 地獄に落ちろという意味なんですけど
それは地獄に落ちろと落ちなさいという意味でも使わないんですね
あっち行けという意味でもありますね
あんた言うことはもうもういい加減にしなさいという意味もあります
だから人がゴートゥヘルと言ったら何意味したかということがね
誤解する可能性もあります
それはないんですね 動物の場合は
なのに人間が優れていると言ってるんですね
論に対して異論もあるから
男女は平等だというと
当然異論もなり 異論を立てる人もいますね
だからそこで人間が男女平等論というのを持ってきたんですね
それ自体がおかしいんでしょうに
だって男も女も人間でしょうに
それでなんで平等というものを持ってくるんですかね
これって失礼なところなんです
だから家族のお母さんが
お父さんがね 自分の子供の中でね
誰が優れているか 誰が優れてないのかと思ったところで
やっぱり自分の子供だからみんな平等やというような言葉なんですね
だからまあ本当はまあ男女平等という言葉を持ってきただけでも
私がすごくイライラするんです
何考えているのかと 論じる側が狂暴であるならば
その論は通用するんです
世の中の論はという そんなもんなんです
で 例えば白人は優れていると
黒人はとんでもない人間やと
教会聖書に出てくるアベルカインとかなんとかとかね
そういう人々の民族やとかね
そういう風に言っちゃうと
この白人の方がもう狂暴でしょ
そこは通じるんですね
黒人がそんなに優れてないんだと
だから科学的に黒人が白人が黒人より優れているということは
一度たりとも証明されたことがないんです
ただ狂暴だけ グループ作っちゃって
何でもかんでも自分だけ全部取ったりして
それでも通じるんですよ
男女平等の論にしたっても
男女は平等であると語る人々が凶暴だったら
そこは通じる 違いますよという人々が凶暴だったら
それは通じる 例えばイスラム文化の中で
女性はもう永久的に立場がないんですね
なぜかというと イスラム教自体もすごい凶暴
力強いんですね それに対して反論することはできなくなってますね
フランスでもね みんな同じでなければ困りますよということで
法律的にね 学校に行く子供たちは頭から全部かぶせておくのはやめましょうと言ったところで
これ狂暴に立ち上がって何するのかいということになって
すごい問題が起きたんですね
だから世の中で通じるのは正しい論ではなくて
強者の狂暴者の論なんですね
そんなのに論には仏教とは乗りません
西洋思想もイスラム思想も
人に強引に押し付けられたものですね
だから我々は西洋思想に汚染されちゃって
なかなかうまくいかない状態になっているんですね
だから国際問題とかね
すべてそのことから出てきて困っているものなんですね
それからイスラム教も世界で一番ものすごい勢いで広がってますけど
ただ教えが正しいんだからじゃなくて
かなり凶暴だからなんです
社会のわずかな一部を偏見で見て
全体を知り尽くしているように語るんですね
その論ずる人々っていうのは
社会のわずかな一部もいるんですね
例えば科学 なんとか発明したとかね
何かもう機械で言いますか
インターナルコンバッションマシンという
今車とか全部エンジンになりますね
それを開発したのはイギリス人で
まあそういういろいろものを開発しているのを見たら
やっぱり白人が偉い すごいと
これっていうのはほんのわずかな一部の証拠だけなんですね
それでもって全体論を語ろうとするんですね
だから まあそれも西洋の方なんですけど
ずっと女性を差別してきて
女性がすごく強くなってきたら
これまずいとわかったところで
まあやっぱり平等論にしましょうとか言って
こちらにまで教えるの
あんた知ってるのかいと
男女は平等だよと しかし
あんた何言うのかというぐらい
我々にアジア人だからできないんですね
そんな話は仏教でないと言ったら
やっぱり仏教は野蛮人の教えやとまた言うんですね
仏教でないんです 男女平等論は
あるはずもないんです
ブッダにしてみれば 人間みんな一色だからね
子供であろうが誰であろうが
お釈迦様はむちゃくちゃカースト制度
人種差別に対してものすごい厳しく語ったんだから
そちらに 女性はあれや
女性もすごいやとかね
言う必要がないんです
えーと 男女平等論は社会が女性を差別してきたという証拠以外何でもありません
今世の中にある男女平等論を読んでみると
読み取れるのはたった一つ
社会が女性を差別してきたんだと
しかし あの論文の内容は大したことないんです
人類が昔から現在まで女性を
これ社会なんですね 社会の表舞台から降ろして抑えてきたんですね
人間がこの 女性を表舞台から強引に降ろすんですね
降板させるんですね これ昔からやっているんです
その事実は簡単に女は男より強いということの証拠になるだけです
だから裏を読んでみてください
やっぱり女が強いんです
だから強引に無理やりに舞台裏から舞台を表舞台から降ろされているだけ
そんなにも苦労して降ろす必要ないでしょうに
弱いんだったら その歴史は生命論でも人間論でもないんです
ですから この男性女性の問題は何なのかという
この歴史的に語っているものっていうのは
何の役にも立ちません
あれは生命論でもないんです
人生論でもないんです
はい これから難しくなります
ですから できるだけ早く喋ります
生命の本質 体 物質と心
感覚という 2つで生命が成り立っている
これからブッダの話です
生命っていうのは肉体と感覚
その 2つでできているんです
物質は合成されているもので
常に変化して変わっていくことで維持されています
もう体の物質っていうのは
この土とか鉄とかね と違います
合成されたものなんですね
あれ 合成するものっていうのは簡単に壊れるんです
で 壊れるとまた復活させなくちゃいけないんですね
そういうことで ずっとこの壊れるわ
直すわ 壊れるわ 直すは壊れる
直すはって それが体なんです
心は体に物質や概念が触れることによって起こるものです
心っていったっても大したことじゃないんですよ
体に何か触れるとわかるんですね
感じるんですね この感じたことについて概念を作ったりするんですね
その機能が心というんですね
絶えず変化することで変わることで維持されています
心もすーっと変わりますよ
人が手を触ったら心が生まれる
その人が足を触ったら
また別な心が生まれる
その人が自分を読んだら
耳で別な心が生まれるということは
心っていうのはものすごい早く変化して変化していくんですね
したがって 生命は変わらないものは何も成り立たない
様々な機能の複雑な絡み合いなのです
だから生命っていうのは
あれやこれやとか いろんな機能が絡み合ったものなんです
そのすべての機能がみるみるうちに変わっていくんですね
はっきり言えば交差点なんですね
あらゆる機能の交差点なんです
生命っていうのは だから生命はこれやっていうことがないんです
空港のようなものですね
パリやら成田とかね 世界中に繋げていると言ったっても
本当に繋げているかどうかよくわからないんだけど
では 男と女って何なのかと
物質的には明らかな違いがあります
男と女といえば物質的な
ちょっと待って もうちょっと脱線して言いたいことがあります
生命の体が物質やとするならば
どこで区別できますか？物質には差別ないでしょうに
区別もないでしょうに
日本から取り出した鉄も
アフリカから取り出した鉄も
鉄に変わりはないでしょうに
日本でできている炭素カーボンの
あのインドネシアから取ってきた炭素も結局は炭素でしょうに
水ならどこの水も同じことでしょう
そういうわけで 体は体で
心も心で 何の上下も何も成り立たないんですね
理論的には 次 これは男と女というテーマに入りますが
皆様に聞きます クイズ出します
女性ということは定義できますか？女性でも女という概念がありますね
定義はできますか 男という言葉がありますね
男とは何と定義できますか
できる方  おそらくできると思いますよ
定義もなく よくもその単語を使ってますよ
あの今日のテーマに関係ないんですが
私は一応定義を教えます
あのはっきり言うと 男というものはあんまり定義難しいんです
曖昧なんです しかし 女性は定義できます
女性っていうのは  これ仏教の見方なんですけど
子孫を作る 子孫を作れる生命体なんですね
次の世代を作れます といえば
次の世代を作れない生命が男性やというより違いますね
だから男性って何かっていう
これを女性男性言うよりも
雄雌にした方がいいんですよ
メールフィメールという言葉に
だからメールはあまり
デフィニションはちょっと難しい
今日考えてないんです
作れますけど 今日はそこを考えてないんです
フィメールというのはデフィニションはできます
プロジェニレーションという次の世界を世代を作りますね
ですから 次の世代を作る生命体はみんなフィメールなんです
だから犬の場合でも カタツムリの場合でも
どちらでもいます ミミズの場合でもいます
それでアメーバの場合もいますよ
例えば皆さんはアメーバのこと知ってますね
アメーバには科学的には性別はないでしょ
しかし アメーバ自分で分解して新しい生命を作るんですね
ということは すべてのアメーバはフィメールなんです
はい それで考えてみてください
生命体の中で一番強いのは誰ですか？と
話にならないね だから子孫を作れるということはもう大変な仕事なんです
それは雌という存在にはできないんです
だから雌という存在がこの存在全体の中にいなくても大丈夫です
じゃあ男がいなかったら子供が生まれないでしょうにと言っても
男がきれいさっぱり消えちゃうと
このフィメールのフィメールボディですね
女性の体が変化するんです
変化して次の世代を作るんです
はい そういうわけで 女性と男性は平等じゃなくて違います
似てないんです 生命の体全体を構成する物質の中で生殖という
これはこれからアビダンマ論なんですけど
バハールーパという働き
物質 2つがあります 仏教の物質論で物質と言ったっても
これはエネルギーなんですね
素粒子なんですね この物質の中 28
種類あります 仏教の物質は
その中で 2つあります
それは生殖と呼ぶんです
それが女性色と男性色ですね
イッティバールーパ プリサバールーパというのはパーリ語の言葉なんですね
ある 2つの物質があるんです
ある2つの互い違いエネルギーがあります
女性色と男性色は一緒に一箇所で存在しないんです
これかなり互い違いなんです
一つのエネルギーともう一つのエネルギーが一緒になると成り立たないんですね
プラスマイナスで消されちゃいます
仏教の物質というのはモノじゃないんですね
エネルギーなんです だからエネルギーの場合は
まるっきり正反対のエネルギーが一緒になると
やっぱりゼロになるか
別のエネルギーになってしまうんですね
だから 女性色というイッティバールーパが体に入っちゃうと
肉体に入っちゃうと男性色というものは入らないんですね
入ったら死ぬしかないんです
体のエネルギーがバランス崩れますからね
常識では 人の体の全細胞に 1種類の生殖があるので
人は男か女なんです まあ常識ではというのはちょっとあまり意味のない単語なんですけど
だから これ 人間だけじゃなくて
体を持っている 体を持っているどんな生命でも男か女なんです
それ仏教の立場 一切の生命
あの生物学的にミミズは男か女かわからないでしょ
あの両性というんですね
両方持ってるんだと 皆様ご存知の科学では
両性の生命もいます カタツムリもそうだと思いますけど
私はもう科学を勉強してないんだからよくわからないんですが
あの両性というカテゴリーがあります
それは科学者見ただけの話で
仏教から見れば ミミズは両性じゃなくて女性なんです
カタツムリは両性ではなくて女性なんです
だって子孫を作るんだから
両方は同じ体には成り立たないんです
では 中性って何？という問題が出てくるでしょ
体を持ってる生命なら論理的には成り立たないんですね
だから仏教の立場では
両性中性っていうのはちょっと成り立たないんですね
たまたま体にそういう機能があるかもしれませんだけど
もっと深いところでははっきり個別なんです
現代医学を発展していますから
部品移植することもできるでしょうね
まだあまりやってないんだけど
やろうとすればできますよ
だから このある部品を見てね
判断するのはちょっとやばいんです
生殖が派手に機能すると性別は明確になります
そこで私たちの体の中で女性色識というエネルギーか男性識というエネルギーが機能していますね
体全体に すべての細胞の中で
そこで他のエネルギーも働いてますよ
その中でこの女性色あるいは男性色でも色でも色ですね
色でもどちらか このまあ 1個しかないんだけど
かなり機能する かなり頑張っちゃうと派手に男か女かっていうことは見えてくるんです
このエネルギーがもう頑張ってるかないかなんですよ
生殖が機能低下か機能しない
いわゆる睡眠状態の場合は
性別は他人にも本人にもわからなくなるんです
こんなことですね 例えば男が生まれる
男が生まれたんだから
男性色が入ってます が
この男性色というエネルギーが仕事しないんですね
あるんだけど あんまり派手に仕事をしない
そうなってくると この人
男か女か何者かとわからなくなるんです
本人に聞いてもわからないんですね
で 皆様 赤ちゃんとかね
もう 1歳  2歳  3歳までの子供のことを知ってるでしょ
その 3歳までの子供の場合は
女の子は生まれてからもうはっきりしています
自分が女やと もう態度でかいし
わがままし もう言うこと聞かないしね
自分で管理しようとするし
男の子は違うでしょ で
男の子はもうなんかこいつは女の子か男かわからない
ですよ 本人もよくわからないんです
小さい時は なぜかというと
男性の場合はこの男性色というこのエネルギーがそんなに派手に機能しないんですね
しかし どんどんどんどん体が大きくなってくると働き出します
その時 自分が男でしたと気がつくんです
それは普通の流れで 時々機能しない場合もあります
その時は本人もよくわからない
自分の性別は何かっていうね
しかし 仏教から見れば
男か女か まあ 2つしかないという
瞑想して禅定に達すると
欲の煩悩は睡眠になります
瞑想して心を統一して禅定状態という人間の次元を超える状態があるんですね
そちらになると この心にある欲の煩悩が機能ストップするんです
煩悩はあるんだけど スイッチオフするんです
で これ大変なことで だから女性でも男性でも瞑想して禅定に達したら
その人の体で働いている
男性職も女性職色もスイッチオフになるんです
じゃあそれからその人はどうするのかいと
まあ違うんですよ それからは
女性が禅定に入ったら
それから女性とは言えなくなっちゃうんですね
男性が禅定に入って上達したら
男性とはちょっと言えなくなっちゃいますね
もっと清らかな優れた状態に達していますね
で そこでその方々は亡くなったら梵天に生まれます
梵天っていうのは生命の一番高い次元なんですね
そちらに生まれたら そこでだけ生殖がないんです
梵天の神々にも体があります
肉体でできている体ではないんだけど
DNA で細胞でできている体ではないんだけど
体があります が そちらには生殖はないんですね
だから仏教から見れば
男か女か言えないのは梵天の神々だけなんです
それでは仏教はそれでは負けませんね
でも輪廻転生だから 今の梵天が梵天になる前に何者でしたかと
梵天に生まれ変わる前の人間で女性でしたならば
あなたは梵天で死んじゃったらね
また女性に戻るでしょうと
だから女性であることは一時休止だけ
男性であることも一時休止だけ
梵天にいる間は はい そういうわけで
劣勢というのは成り立ちませんと
物質は互い違います しかし
水より土が優れているということも
その反対も成り立ちませんね
物質は違いますよ 水と土は違うんですけど
しかし 水には俺の方が偉いと言えないでしょうに
土にも俺の方が偉いと言えないでしょうに
区別はあるが平等なのです
というわけで 男性色女性色というはっきり互い違いの働き
2つあるんですけど ただの物質ですね
だから区別はあるんだけど
平等ということになるんです
価値とは人間が勝手に主観で入れるものです
それ自体が無知な行為です
物事に価値を入れることっていうのは
もう愚かな人間がやっていることなんですよ
金は鉄より高いとかね
炭素なのにダイヤの方が高いとかね
あれは愚かな人間がやっていることで
どうったことだ ないんです
したがって 一切の生命は体を持っていることで平等ですが
性別という区別があるんです
それはあるセクションの結論なんですね
生命の体から見るとみんな平等なんですけど
体の中で男性女性という差がありますから
区別は成り立ちます はい
それから性別のいろいろ
生殖の力が低下することはあります
あり得る これは業が原因なんですね
これがあり得ますよ 例えば人がいる
男だとしましょう このあるエネルギーが働いていますね
男性意識という これがじわじわと低下することはあり得ます
なんで男を例出すかというと
現実的にこれは起こりやすいのは男なんです
女性の場合はほとんど起こらないんです
男性ってやばいんですよ
で で これは業の力だというんですね
この物質を維持管理するのは業なんですね
そこで男性意識というエネルギーを維持する業が何か力弱くなってくると
男性意識というエネルギーが低下していくんですね
低下していると 男で生まれたのに
男としての男性らしいことっていうのは消えていっちゃうんですね
もしそのエネルギーが消えてゼロになったとしましょう
男性意識はゼロになったら生命は成り立たないんですよ
どうしても性意識が必要なんです
それで男性意識がゼロになった時点で女性意識が入っちゃうんです
入ってそれがじわじわとエネルギーが出しちゃうと
もう女になっているんです
それは論理的にはあり得る
証拠はあの人この人ということはちょっと言いづらいんですけど
仏典には一応エピソードはあります
これはあり得るんだと
だから男性の方々 気をつけてください
それから別な正式正式に変わるのです
男性が女性になったり
女性が男性になったりすることも論理的にはあり得ます
現在 転換手術でしたっけ？施しても男は男です
生殖は変わらないと性別は変わらないんです
今 無理をしてね 男の体を女にしたり
女の体を男にしたりします
あれは無理やってるだけで
あのそれでは男に女になりません
科学者のからくりでは
これを科学用語を使うならば
DNA の中で 遺伝子の中で
染色体の中で変化しなきゃダメなんですね
医学でも染色体と染色体の話があるでしょ
染色体はもうエックスとワイとあって
もう XS は女性でしたっけ？ YY 女性かわかりませんだけど
XY は男性なんですね
ということは 現代的なね
医学的な話から見ても
やっぱり男性の方がやばいんですね
で だからそこを変えない限り
この染色体を変えない限りは
男は女にしたということはあり得ないんです
それは仏教ではそういう知らなかったしね
DNA の話も何もね 染色体なんかは知らなかったでしょう
最近の発明発明だから
しかし 仏教はエネルギー論で言ってるんですね
様々なエネルギーでできているんだと
その中でそういう生殖というエネルギーが働いています
以上の説明はアビダンマ論によるものです
性別の説法は経典ではありません
お釈迦様はそういうことを無駄な時間だからね
男はなに 女はなにやって説法したってもね
お釈迦様も科学者ですからね
無駄なことをやりたくないんです
生命はなにということを喋ってますよ
だから この今までの男女
男は男です 女は女ですという話は
アビダンマ論から出したんです
はい 体の性別は語りました
では 心に性別はありますかね
心には性別はありません
体が女性なら思考は女性的になります
価値判断 感情なども女性であることを中心にします
ただ それだけ 心には性別はないんです
心が宿っていると 体が女の体だったら
その心は女性的に感情を
思考を持っちゃいます
男性の体に入った心が
もう男性的な好き嫌い
感情 あれやこれや作ったりするんです
女の子に男のおもちゃをあげたら
男の子と同じく遊ぶんですよ
皆様それ知ってるだろうと思いますけど
この子供は小さい時はあまり体のことは気にしないんです
心のエネルギーはすごいんです
子供心 ものすごい元気なんですけど
体が弱いんでしょうね
体が弱いんだけど ものすごい力があります
あれが心がパワフルなんです
心はあまりにもパワフルだから
子供遊ぶ遊ぶは いくら遊んだっても疲れないわ
その時は子供の中では男女ということはほとんどないんです
そこで親なんですね この男にすること
女にすることをするのは
あなた女の子だからお人形で遊んでくださいと
あなたは男の子だから車のおもちゃで遊んでくださいと
これ大人がやってるんです
生まれてきた男の子にお人形さんをあげれば
お人形と遊ぶんです 全然問題ないんです
小さな女の子に電車とか電車のオモチャとか車のおもちゃとかね
あげたらへっちゃらで遊ぶんです
ということは 心にはそんなに性別的な区別はないんです
時々ね お母さんがお化粧するのを見て
息子さんもね ちっちゃな息子さんもね
あっちこっち塗ったりする可能性はあります
お母さんがびっくり 何やってるの？あんた男の子でしょうにと言ったって子供はよくわからない
何？なんで塗って悪いのかと
それだけ だからお化粧に性別つけたのは我々人間なんです
親が子供の性別意識を刷り込むんですね
この世間にある性別意識っていうのは
親が刷り込むものなんです
男らしい女らしい社会は
は社会の決まりです 男らしい
女らしいっていうのは
社会が決まることであって
本質的なものではないんです
女心 男心は演歌だけの話です
現実ではないんです しかし
体が心に影響を与えているのです
したがって 女の体を持っている生命の気持ち
思考 感情 生き方などは女性という方向に傾く
向くんです 男も同じです
心には性別がないんだけど
この肉体にあるんですね
だから肉体の影響を受けて
心の機能が女性の方か男性の方に傾いていくんです
また 心が体を管理するんです
逆もあります 心が体を管理する
過去世の影響もあって
思考感情が女性的になったら
男の体でもそれに合わせて変化するんです
例えば 過去世で女が 人間で男で生まれるとしましょう
で 過去世で女の女でしたから
心は女色に染めているんです
価値観 思考 傾いてるんですね
それで突然新しい体もらったんですけど
男の体はね その体を維持する心がまだまだ女性的なんですね
その場合はアイデンティティの問題が起こるんです
日本ではたまたまありますね
自分にはアイデンティティの問題が起きたっても
これしょうがないんです
だからって男はわざわざ女になる必要はないんです
体見たら男だったら男のしきたり
習慣 価値観を身につければいいんです
心に性別はないんです
だから心の問題は長い間訓練した方向に行きやすい
そういうことで女の人もいますよ
かつて男で輪廻の中の過去世でね
男でいたならば なんか心が男的なんですね
それで女の体に入り込んじゃったら
困ったもんで 困ったもんでとかね
どうしようかということになっちゃうんです
誰でも一部異性の因子を持っているのかいと
これ世間がそう言いますけどね
人はいくらか異性の性質を持っているでしょうか
それも世間の考えですね
世間はそう思いますよ
男にもいくらか女の気持ちやらね
機能やあるだと あるんだと
女性にも男らしいというか
ところはあるんだと いうのは社会が言ってることで
あまり仏教はそんなことは考えてないんですね
だって輪廻転生を言ってますから
我々は過去で男でいたか
女でいたか それわからないでしょうに
これは変わります 派手じゃないんだけど
ある程度で変わります
ですから まあ気持ち的にはそれもあり得るんです
心には性別がないので
何でも妄想することができます
はい 心には性別はないんだけど
妄想はできます 気持ち
感情を変えることはできます
教育 訓練を受けて変えることもできます
心は変えられますよ だから男の心を完全に女の心に変えられることはできます
女性の心もあらゆるマインドコントロールで男性の心に変えることはできます
それから その心の影響は体に表れます
例えば 生まれてきた女の子を
すっと親が男の子欲しかったんだからということでね
男として育てる それも時々ありますよ
子供が生まれたんですけど
女の子でした それもお母さんもお父さんも男の子が欲しかったと
そうなってくると もう娘さんを男にして育てるんですね
あげるおもちゃも買ってあげる服も
喋り方も何でもかんでも
お父さんが遊ぶ時でも男の子やという感じで
そういう遊びしたりとかね
そういうことをやっていると
女の子の心 体だけ女の子なんですけど
心の教育は男になっちゃうんですね
そうなってくると その女性の体にも影響を与えちゃうんです
他の女の子が年代とともに体の変化が起きますけど
これ起きなかったり 遅くなったり
いろいろ起こります 男にも女性的な心があるなどの話は異常な働きの結果なんですね
こういう働きがありますから
世の中はそういうことを言ってます
次に私を理解してくれないというね
私のことでもないんですけどね
誰でも自分を理解してほしいと
あるいは掃除機械と聞きたいんですよ
と絶望するんですね 人間というのは本当に自分のことを理解して欲しくないんです
が 理解してほしいと言うんです
男に女を 女に男を理解することは無理です
自分の主観で相手の気持ちを妄想して一緒に生きているが
毎日はトラブルの連続です
これは人間の社会のことで
みんな結婚している方々は
女性の方々は 自分の気持ちはこの旦那
全然理解してくれませんとずっと文句言ってますね
男の人も同じなんですね
この女はいつたっても自分の気持ちをわかってくれないんだと
だからお互い気持ちが分かち合えばいい夫婦になるんではないかと
一向になりません で これ理解できないんです
なんでならないかというと
男が持っている女性像があるんですね
その角度で自分の奥さんのことを見ているんです
で 女性も男性はそうであるべきやと
女性が描いた絵があるんですよ
その角度で見ているんです
だからお互い理解できなくなっているんです
それがどれほど違うかと
現代は調べることできます
女性作家が書いている小説と男性作家が書いている小説を並べて読んでみてください
そうすると 同じシーンはどのように書いているのかと
例えば 初めて会った人に恋に落ちてしまう
シーンは同じでしょ そこで女性作家がどんな風にこの場面を展開して持っていくのかと
男性の作家がどのようにその場面を展開してみるのかと比べて読むと
大きな差が見えるはずなんです
全くも似てないんです
私はもう怠け坊主だから
そういう研究する必要はないんですけど
皆様頑張っていますから
ちょっと研究してみてください
女性作家が書いている小説と小説でなければダメです
ノンフィクションはダメです
ノンフィクションはそんな大したことないんです
小説です フィクションでなければダメなんです
だから 女性作家のフィクションと男性作家のフィクション
それで比較するのは同じ場面
恋に落ちる場面 あるいは恋が潰れて別れる場面
あるいは一緒になって性交をする場面とかね
そういう似ている場面を比較してみてください
ものすごくそれている違い
違います 何で違うかというと
女性が性のことを書く場合は
女性の頭にある男性イメージで戦わせるんで演じさせるんです
男はそういう恋の場面を書く場合は
男が持っている女性のイメージでこの舞台を演じさせるんですね
そういうことで 男には女は理解できないし
女にも男のことを理解できないってことは私は決めました
育てるという天職があるので
女性は相手のことをわかっているという錯覚に陥って困ることが男性よりも多いんです
世の中でトラブルを起こすといえば
女の方が多いんですね
肉体的トラブルは男は起こしますけど
国際的な問題とかね 戦争とかね
それはあまり長持ちはしません
壊れますからね 女性っていうのは
そういう大きな戦争などを起こしませんだけど
24時間何かトラブルを起こすんですね
何かしら何でもトラブルなんです
そこはなんで起こるのかというと
女性っていうには天職があるんですね
この天職っていうのは
子供 子供というか 子孫ですね
産んで育てる だから産んで育てる天職がこの体の中に
心  DNAの中に入ってますから
錯覚に陥るんですよ 相手のことはわかっているんだと
赤ちゃんが泣いたら あ
お腹が空いただろうと
あ もう眠くなってるだろうとかね
あまり合ってないでしょ
あれも でも認めないでしょ
時々お母ちゃんが泣いてると
まあ眠くなってるだろうと思って寝かしつける
寝ないんですね 何だろうねとかね
もしかするとお腹が空いてるかもしれません
おっぱいあげて吸わない
合ってないんでしょうに
合ってないんだけど 認めたくはないんですよ
なんで認めたくないのかというと
これどうしようもないんです
バカだからじゃあからじゃないんです
あれ 天職のせいなんです
やっぱりいくらなんでも私が泣き止めさせなくちゃいけないんだと
これ 私の仕事だと だから認めないんですね
子供が泣いているのは
泣いていることは自分に理解できないということはね
そういうことで それから子供がどんどん大きくなってくると
あれやこれやで行ったり来たり
話し合ったり ずっとお母さんとべったり大きくなるでしょうに
お母さんが錯覚に陥るんですね
あ 子供のことならわかっているんだと
それがお母さんではなくて
女性になってくると 人の気持ちなんかわかっているんだと思っちゃうんですね
あれ すごい錯覚なんです
それでどこへ行っても何か何かしらトラブルちゃう
んです しかし 男が作るトラブル
トラブルほど 派手で大きいものではないんですね
だから精神的な問題 カウンセラーに行く人々を分けてみると
女性の方が多いし で 悩み事といえば
女の人には多いし あれって別にどうってことなくて
これは天職の問題なんですね
人のことではなく 我が子の気持ちもわからないものです
だから これ 女性の方々は気をつけた方がいいんです
自分がわかったつもりで
旦那にいろんなことをやってあげたり
友達にいろんなことをやってあげたりしたっても
結果が逆になる場合はいくらでもあります
だから このわかったつもりはなんとか修行してでも抑えた方がいいんです
なぜならば 現実は我が子の気持ちもわからないんです
理解する方法 相手の気持ちをどうやって理解しますかと
性別意識を控えて 生命は生命として慈しんで見るんです
慈しんで見るんです 男も女も消してください
人間も動物も消してください
生命であると 生き物であると
まずそこが必要なんです
性別によって生まれる思考感情などを無視する
無視するんです 生命として共通している思考
気持ち 感情などを観察するんです
そこで人間もと消しちゃって
すべて生命だと見る 男女も消しちゃう
消してみると 生命の共通感情が見えてくるんです
一切生命の共通感情 それが手にとったら
残りはもう何のこともないんです
このように まず自分と同じ似ているところを発見するんです
それから違っているところを発見するんです
どこか違いますかと 思っているほど容易いことではありませんかもしれませんだけど
これが人の気持ちを理解する方法なんです
それほど簡単ではないんです
はい どうしますか？休憩とか取りますかね
ちょっとわからない 全部終わってから
うん じゃあ半分が進みました
もっと簡単な話だと思っていたでしょうと思いますけどもね
やっぱり仏教っていうのは
そういう厳密に精密に語るもの
世界なんです 世間にあるだらしない男女論は語りません
はい 次は女性論に入ります
女性とは何かという 控えめには女性の辞書にない単語です
よく言うでしょうね 女だからもうちょっと控えめで一歩下げてとかね
あれは嘘ですよ 辞書にないんです
女性は生命を管理するんです
この場合 女性っていうのは
この FEMALE というすべての生命の FEMALE なんです
新たな生命を作って育てることは女性の天職です
人間を作ることは神にもできないが
女性なら簡単にできます
でしょうにね 人間も作ったっていうのはたった二人だけでしょ
女に聞いてみてください
どれぐらい人間作っているのかと
だから女性っていうのは神よりすごい
もうもう点数は高いんです
人間作ることは神にもできないのに
女の人はいとも簡単に作ります
まあ女の人って人間なんですけど
どんなあの性 あの FEMALE というか
メスの生命も簡単に作れます
ね タコとかね 鮭とかね
いっぺんに卵何個産むんですかね
4000個とか どうだいね
この数は 一人の鮭さんが 4000個卵を産んだところで
全部ちゃんと受精して魚になったならば
幼虫稚魚になったならばすごい生命でしょうに
あれ 神には無理です いかなる生命であっても
女性 作られて育てられて躾されたものです
生命っていうのは女性に作られて育てられて躾られているんです
これは猿の猿であろうか
猫であろうが虎であろうが
もうどうでも関係ないんです
女性蔑視する人であっても
女性にそのように躾されたからその性格になるんです
特に男の世界では女性蔑視する男がいるでしょ
あれもあの性格も女性が育てたんです
だから私が言いたいのは
女性蔑視する男が偉くないんですよ
お前女言う通りにやってるでしょうにと
けしからんやという話なんです
あんた何言ったっても
これお母さんが言ったことでしょうにと
現実はそうなんでしょ
皆さんはそれを無視してる可能性あります
男はすごいんだと もう母親が叩くんだから
そういう変な人間が生まれます
男は台所に来るなよとか
それもこれはあんた男だろうとかね
あれやこれやと言って
男はもう何というか 男尊女卑でしたっけ
そこのその気持ちさえも女性が
刷り込んでいるんです
今更私たち弱い男たちに文句言わないでくださいとも言いたいところなんです
で 男は威張って何言ったっても
裏の糸を引いているのは女性なんです
地球の引力から離れないように
生命は女性の影響からは解放されません
大変なことですよ 怖いんです
我々地球上にいる生命には
引力からは逃げられないでしょうに
だったら 生きている生命には
女性に糸を引いて引かれていることからはもう逃げられないんです
それで管理の仕方が 女性っていうのは管理者だから
これすごい達人なんですよ
あらゆる方法で自分が産んだ生命を管理するんです
管理者として管理する場合
管理者として管理する場合あります
いわゆる上からこうしなさい
ああしなさい 今寝なさいとかね
すごい命令調子で管理する場合もあります
たまたま私も見たんですけど
この男たちはものすごいこの凶暴になったりとかね
ヤクザみたいに喧嘩して人殺しにまで行ったりしてね
そこでもう大喧嘩になってるんだよと
包丁を持って人を刺そうとしてるんだよと
そこは年取ってるお母さんが聞いたら
なんのことなく そいつ喧嘩
男たち堂々と喧嘩してる場面に行くんです
言って お前何やってるの？家に帰りなさい
一言で帰るんです 男たちが抑えを抑えとしたっても無理なんです
抑えていても あいつを殺してやるぞと思ってるんですね
それでお母さんが出て
お前家に帰りなさいと言ったところで
なんのことか はい わかりましたと
あの力っていうのはもうどうしようもないんです
これ逆らえないんです
もう中から管理されているんです
これは 1 番目の管理の方法なんです
話し合って説得して管理する場合もあります
この話し合いも女性が上手でしょ
会社の場合でも 他の会社でなかなか話し合いがうまくいかなくて
何て言いますか 最後の契約サインできないとかなんとか言ったらね
女の人を出しちゃえばいいんです
どうしても自分の会社がその契約を取りたければ
女の人を送っちゃえばね
負けませんね とにかくサインしてもらって帰るんです
で 話し合うことも女性の方がすごくできるんです
結局 この男みたいに話し合って理解して
お互いじゃあ調停を結びましょうということじゃないんです
あれ 管理なんです 私が言う通りにやりなさいなんです
女帝 鬼のように独裁的に管理する場合もあります
時々女性っていうのは女帝になっちゃう
鬼になるんですね 独裁者になる場合もあります
それも別にもう悪いことをする気持ちはないんです
ただ管理したいだけ はいはい
ご主人様とか旦那様調子で管理する場合もあります
秋葉原のなんか店とかあるでしょ
なんか女の子が変な服装を着て
はい 旦那様とかね あの
なんて言いますか ソフトクリームとか食べさせてあげたりとかね
ご主人様の機嫌いかがでしょうかとかね
なんか男たち調子に乗っちゃって
なんかご主人 ご主人様になった気分で
バカですね あれ 管理されてるんです
まんまと見事に管理されているんです
控えめ 控えめを演じて管理するのは効率が高いんです
この管理の中で控えめを演じた方が効率高いんです
多数派はこれを使います
あれは演じです 嘘だと思う
女性に聞いてみてください
だから問題は 皆様お互いに理解できないでしょう
男性と女性がね こちらが仏教の連中は違います
だから我々はもうこの修行をやってますから
生命として観察して理解する
訓練するんだから まあ何のことなくそういうことを聞いたら堂々と言うんです
命を育む 生むこと 育てること
守ること 心配することなどは
女性の体に遺伝的に遺伝的情報です
遺伝的情報っていうのは現代人間の言葉ですけど
仏教は使ってはいけない単語なんです
仏教から言えば 意識的に入ってるんでよということなんです
心にもその記録は無意識的にあります
だから 女性の体を持った人の心にも
この情報がすーっと無意識に入っているんです
ですから 優しく接すること
応援すること 面倒見ることなどでも
それから助けてもらう
守ってもらう 養ってもらうなどの態度でも
とにかく女性は他の生命を管理するんです
何か異論があったら言ってください
時々女性が私はやっぱり男に助けてもらってますよと
養ってもらいましょうと感謝していますよと言うでしょ
だけど男は調子に乗るんです
やっぱり女性は弱いんだからね
男は助けてあげなくちゃとかね
必死で仕事をして贅沢させてあげなくちゃと思うでしょ
けど 女の人ははいはい
その通りです おかげさまで楽々に
あれは嘘です 結局はその男を管理しているんです
それから女性っていうのは
本来優しいという 考えが世の中にあるでしょ
本来は優しいんです それは嘘じゃないんです
簡単に喧嘩するのは男なんです
しかし あまりシャレにならないね
あの優しさが あれ すごく優しくて
すごく行儀良くて 振り回す
ことによって管理しちゃうんです
だって逆らえないでしょ
だから現に私個人の場合でも
人いうことは全く聞かないんです
ものすごい頑固なんです
男は 400人集めて 私に対してこうしないで言ったって
私は一人で違いますよと言うんです
全然気にもしない しかし
女性がいくらか優しく
まあそんなこと言わないでね
やっぱりみんな言ってるんだからと言ったら
はい わかりましたと 何のことなくやるんです
やりながら私はあれ これって何や？と
私はもともとやりたくなかったでしょうにと
で なんでやっているのかと
やっぱりこの女性っていう
この生命体はもう男性という生命体を管理するんです
そういうことなんです
だから私も生き物だから
その糸を操られている
糸からはもう解放されないんです
それは結婚しているとか関係ないんです
結婚しないで独身でいるとかね
我々みたいに出家しているんだとかね
そんなこと言ったっても
行ってみてください タイとかミャンマーとかスリランカとか
お寺どうですかと 全部女性が管理しているんだ
なぜ女性を これを何て言ったっけ？軽視
蔑視 なんで女性蔑視がある
ユダヤ人が劣等感で病んでいて作った妄想した神は何を隠そう男性でした
ユダヤ人がかなり精神的に劣等感で悩んでいて
精神的な病気でしたから
神話物語を作ったんですね
その中で全知全能の神を作ったんですね
そいつが男なんですね
これ 全知全能でした これから独裁者でした
どんな問題があっても
それは女性のせいにしたんです
だからこの聖書っていうのは
結構 旧約聖書っていうのはだいたい 3000年ぐらい紀元前にね
話が始まった時から古いと思ってるんですね
本当はテキストはそれほど古くないんだけど
一応考えはね 古いんですね
だからその時作った神話物語で
何があったらっても女のせいとするんです
皆さんは旧約聖書の1から5番目までの本を読んでみてください
それは一番古いんです
女性が読んじゃうと 理性で読んじゃうと
もう機関銃持ちたくなりますよ
それぐらい女性を蔑視しているんです
では 一つだけれども 皆様誰でも知っている
なんで人間が永遠な楽園から追い出されたんですかね
神が作った人間が永遠の人間だったそうです
病気にもかからないで
永遠に生きているはずでしたけど
今死んじゃいますね 短い時間で
それから生きることもすごい苦しいでしょ
その理由は何でしたっけ？イブが知恵の実を男に食べさせたんだからなんです
だから男も女も今は苦しんでいるのは
結局は女のせいだと よく言うんです
今まで各民族の神はほとんど女神でしたけどね
ああいう変な神を作る前に
各地方で 人間が神を信仰してきたんです
どこを調べても 原始時代の人間が拝んでいた神は女神なんです
女なんです そこで太陽も神だと思っている場合あるでしょ
太陽は神だと思っている人々は
大地も神だと思っている
信仰するんですね そうすると太陽が男性で大地が女性なんです
今のインド文化では 大地には恵み女神と呼ぶんですね
あれ 大地の同義語なんです
我々太陽で生活するわけじゃないでしょうに
ただちょっと上で回っているだけで見張られているだけで
実際は芋を掘って食べている場合はね
あの稲をとって食べている場合は
全部大地からいただいているんですね
寝る時でも大地に寝ているんですね
だから一番ありがたい神は女性なんです
ヒンドゥー教の場合は絶対神はブラフマンとも言いますけど
このブラフマはどちらかというと男か中性かはっきりしないんですね
あんまり男性っていうことはないんです
それから現代インドの人々を信仰するヒンドゥー教では
何を拝むかというと こういうところで言いたくはないんだけど
ヒンドゥー教の寺院は中は立ち入り禁止なんです
私もそれは認めます なぜかというと
一番拝んでる御神体というのは
女性の生殖器官と上に男性の生殖器官をつけちゃって
そこを拝んでるんです
だからやっぱり子供が立ち入り禁止っていうのはね
まあ気持ちわかります
で まあ仏教はそういう信仰はないんだけど
やっぱりその場合も男性礼ということはないんです
両方なんですね これと所詮
この中東でこのイカれた考え方が生まれたんです
ユダヤ系の神の影響が世界に広がって
女性蔑視する世界が現れたんです
だからこのこちらのせいじゃないんです
男女平等会っていうことでね
女性中心になった宗教
文化 政治 経済に反発して現れた流行っている男女平等思考も大した思考ではありません
単純にあれに反発しているだけでね
その人々もこの宗教と文化の枠の中で妄想しているから
社会に新たな問題を作るだけです
だから今 このウーマンスリベレーションムーヴメントとかね
ウーマンズあれやこれやと迷惑
日本でもありますよ 女性党という政党が
あれ 相当迷惑やと思いますけど
女性党なんかいらんでしょうに
日本国民のことを心配してる党が欲しいんだけど
だからそういう思考がいつでもどう見たっても
中東から出てきた文化の影響なんです
だから男性男女平等だというために
みんな必死で聖書を読んで探すんですよ
何かデータがあるのかい？とかね
見つからないんですね
そうすると自分勝手に解釈するんです
これ考えてください 天皇は私は天皇だと叫びませんね
支配者である女性がなぜ平等にしてくれと叫ぶんですかね
おかしいでしょうね 女性はそんなにも平等になりたいと思うならばね
なんか天皇陛下が我は天皇だよと言っているようなことで
ちょっとおかしいでしょ
おっしゃったならば だから私が言いたいのは
女性はね 平等にしてくれとかね
あれあれこれ叫ぶこともね
ちょっとあんた方勘違いしてるんじゃないですか？と
もうちょっと自分たちの力を信じなければ
平等じゃなくなる もう支配者になれるでしょうに
かえってね なんかおかしいんです
もう自分の要求 不満などをリストアップして出せば
徐々にでも世界は飲み込むしかないんです
例えば 世界の女性たちが自分たちの希望
世界はどうなるべきか
家族はどうなるべきか
国際関係どうなるべきかと女性たちがリストを作って出せば
みるみるうちにそれ通じちゃうんです
誰にもそれは逆らえなくなっちゃうんです
本当は女性たちが自分の仕事をしていないんです
だから文句を言うべきだと私は思いますよ
国が平和でして欲しければ
国民は豊かにして欲しければ
戦争は嫌であるならば
これは女性たちが決めて
これこれやりなさいと政治やっている男たちに命令すれば
あー困ったな 困ったので言ってますけど
強暴で言えばね じわじわじわじわじわと変わっていくんです
世界は だからこのこれも女性が自分の責任を忘れていますよ
これ なんで女性が自分の責任という天職を忘れたかというと
現代地球はみんな西洋文化思考ですから
なんです はい まあ可哀想だから男性論も
任された仕事を真面目にしなさいなんです
脇役なんですね 男性は存在の中で
女性という生命体を支えること
命令されるように行うことが男性の天職なんです
新たな命を作る時でも
わずかな仕事しか することはないんです
男には 男が仕事 政治 軍事
技術などで旗を上げるのは
生命としての脇役がエキストラ程度だったからです
我々男たちが脇役なんで
エキストラなんですね
英語 映画でいえば主役じゃないんです
あれ エキストラだからまあ暇がありすぎなんですね
映画の場合は主役は忙しいでしょう
映画の初めから終わりところまで演じなくちゃあかんでしょ
脇役 エキストラっていうのは
その時その時なんですね
エキストラの仕事は時々 30 秒で終わる場合もあります
だから男にっていうのは無茶暇があるんです
この暇があるんだから
仕事をするは 政治をやるは
戦争もするは 軍隊も作るは
技術開発もするは 機械作っているの全部男でしょ
あの女性も発明品作りますけど
全部大所用品なんですね
役に立たないものは発明しないんです
それでは男に任せてください
いくらでも作れます 役に立たないもの
あるちっちゃな男の子がいて
いつでも何か作品 創作品を作るんですね
色段ボール箱で段ボールでね
あれやこれやとかね で
まあ子供が作るものだからね
まあゴミばっかりですけど
で 私はある日 この子供にこういうことを言ったんですね
あのね 君 君の作品が万が一でももし役に立ったらどうしようかねとか
そしたらもう笑って終わっちゃったんですけど
大変なことになりますねとかね
で 本人もわかってて 自分が毎日いろんな作品を作るんだけど
私に持ってくるんですよ
これは鉛筆立てとかね
何かね ビニールじゃなくて
ペットボトルでね 紙を貼ったりして
ゴムバンドで留めたりして
まあ当然鉛筆は入れ替えられますけど
使えないでしょ で ゴミになるし
まあ男はいろいろ創作品やらね
機械やら何でも発明します
が 役には立ちません 機関銃とかね
鉄砲とかね 弓とか それから原子爆弾とかね
それから宇宙船とかね
役に立ったことないでしょ
あの 何て言いますか 宇宙望遠鏡とか
あれ何にも役に立ってないんです別に
ただ見たことのない写真撮ってるだけで
だから何ですかと  例えば日食の時は必死で空を飛んで
あるいは宇宙船とか そこから写真撮るとか
だからよくわかった この働きはとか
だから何ですかね あんた肉じゃが作れるのかい？と
肉じゃが作るならばでしょうに
命が支えるのは だから男っていうのはそうやってもうあらゆる技術開発するんです
まあ九十パーセント役に立ちません
女に怒られると役に立つことも作ります
はい その理由があります
生命の世界ではエキストラなんですね
その場面終わったらはい
さようならなんです 皆様が映画のことをご存知でしょう
時々 例えば 町とかね まあどこか
例えば  何でしたっけ  グラウンドのね
この主役は何か演じなくちゃいけない
演じるの時間は三十秒
グラウンドで会って あ
こんにちは あ この間これあんたから借りた本ですけど
はい 返します ありがとう
それで終わり 三十秒 しかし
グラウンドでしょ だからグラウンドで一人が野球やって
一人はキャッチャーボールやっていて
一人が走っているとか
いっぱいこの雰囲気が必要なんですね
それは全部エキストラの脇役なんです
だからみんな一生懸命演じていますけど
三十秒で終わり それからあのスタッフが車にバスに乗って
また別なところに行くんです
あのグラウンドで集めた人々は家に帰るしかないんです
そういうことで その生命の中で脇役なんですね
男性っていうのは だから男性には暇があるんですね
その暇で仕事をするんです
政治もやるんです 戦争もするんです
それから技術開発もするんです
結局は女性の教わしているだけですよ
全部まとめてみると 男は女性の教わしているだけ
それ人生はうまくいくんです
しかし 脇脇役は出過ぎだったらまずいでしょうに
これがよく起きてるんですね
存在の主役である女性に自由はないんです
怒らないでください 女性には自由がないんです
自由があるのは男性なんです
偉くなると誰でも同じことです
あまり偉くならない方がいいんです
存在の中で女性が唯一偉いんですね
その分自由がないんです
日本でも一般人にはいっぱい自由があるでしょう
国会議員になってみてください
自由がなくなる 大臣になってみてください
さらに自由がなくなる
総理大臣になってみてください
むちゃくちゃ自由がなくなるんです
天皇になって 考えてみてください
身動きもできなくなるんです
それを勘違いした男性は
自分が何でもやっているのだと思い込み
女性を支配しようとしてきたのです
女性が自由がないんだから
例えばこの 竹の竹をどう組み立てれば飛行機になるのかと
女性は考えません 女性はこの
何といいますか サツマイモを茹でるか焼くかということで精一杯なんです
それで男はもう竹を持ってきて
割って引いて結んで バランスを見て紙を貼って飛ばしてみるんですね
これで現実でしょ 普通でも奥さんが一生懸命おにぎりを作って握られる間は
お祭りの時は男たちは凧を作って空を飛ばしているんです
そこで男たちがえらいことやっていると勘違いしているんです
あれが暇があるからなんです
暇があるんだから いろんなことをできるんです
竹竹を上げて高さを競争する祭りの場合でも
これ全部男たちやってるんです
しかし 女の方がものすごい仕事をしていますよ
これ終わったらみんなに食べ物を配らなくちゃいけない
おにぎりを作ったり お味噌汁を作ったり
もう大変です だから女ってのはいつでも同じことをやってますから
面白くないやと 私たちの方が偉いと思ってる
それ錯覚ですよ だから女性支配しようとするんですね
自然法則に逆らったこの生き方が優先になったので
この男性中心にした社会はうまく機能していないんです
現代社会 この西洋型の社会は男性中心ですね
一度たりともうまくいったことがないんです
はい 別な問題 正統学者は常に男性
あの正統学者っていうのはブッダのことなんです
正統学者サンマサンブッダになるのは男性です
女性はなりません これは一般人に理解できない不可思議な法則の一つです
という言葉があります
経典にあります 長部経典にもありますし
一部一部中部経典にもあります
人間に理解できない不可思議な項目がいくつかありますよと
この中で一つ 正統学者になるのは男やと
女は無理やと 不可能やと
ありえないんだと すごい女性蔑視ですね
これは生命論なんです
女性蔑視じゃないんです
女性には自由がないんです
女性たるものは 猫であろうか
犬であろうか 自由がないんです
あのライオンのとかね
あのテレビで見てください
オスは食って寝るだけで
メスはどれほど忙しいかというと
命を守ることと違ったことにも挑戦してみる暇と自由が男性にのみあるんです
女性が命を守る 守る 守るばっかしで
微塵も暇がないんです
男性にはもう守られてもらってるんだから自由ですね
だから命を守るだけじゃなくて
何か別なことあるのかいと探して
命を乗り越えることに挑戦するということは
これは決まって男にしかできないんです
だから この人間に不可思議やと
お釈迦様がおっしゃったのに
私はすごい失礼なことしてしまったんです
この意味を今日説明したんです
言葉だけ見たらなんか女性蔑視なんですけど
これは女性蔑視じゃなくて生命論なんです
生命として女性には自由がないんだから
余計なこと何もできないんです
命に関係ないことには暇がないんです
だからいろんなことに飛行機を作ることにも
宇宙旅行することにも挑戦するのは暇有り余っている男性たちなんですね
男が金棒を持つと 女性は匙を持つのです
これなんですね ポイントは金棒を持って何するのかというと
余計なことでしょ 匙を持ったらどうするんですかというと
命に必要なことでしょう
この差が一生でもあります
それでも男は惨め 女性は男性によって満足し
満足しないのだという経典の言葉があります
経典にありますよ 女性っていうのは全然男性に満足しないんだと
なんか嫌な言葉のように聞こえるでしょ
性行為に限った話ではありません
性欲はさまざまバラバラですからね
生命を作ることで男性は精子を与えるだけです
受精はできません 子育ては 0.5%は男性で
95.5%は女性なんですね
対等で責任を持つべきなのに
子孫を育てる場合は対等で作らなくちゃあかんでしょうに
しかし 男はもう 0.5%の役割で
はい さようならと 女性が 95.5%責任を持ってるでしょ
これが腹が立ちますよ
これなら不満は当然です
入るならない じゃあ残りは自然法則にしましょう
これを慌てて書いたんだから間違いです
計算間違い  それでもいいと思いますよ
子供っていうのは別に自然にも育ちますからね
そういうわけで いっそでも女性がわかってないんです
どこで不満を持ってるのかと
これはこの生命対等として
この子育てでは助けてくれないんですね
遊びばっかりやっているんですね
これにはものすごく腹が立っているんです
すごく不安を感じているんです
はい 煩悩と男女論 当然煩悩にも性別はありません
時間ないんだから飛ばします
しかし 煩悩も体と心を通じて出現しなくてはいけないんです
それで男の欲 女の欲 男の怒り
女の怒りという差が現象的に見えます
怒りには性別はないんです
しかし 煩悩は体に表現しなくちゃいけないんですね
だから怒りは女の体で表現すると女の怒り
怒りを男の体で表現すると男の怒り
仏教の説法の場合 瞑想指導の場合も
相手が女であること 男であることを取り消します
仏教の場合は取り消します
説法は人間に語るんであって
全然気にもしないと 男か女かということを
しかし 修行の最初の段階段階では女性の差は見えます
修行を始めたら男が始まるでしょ
だから男として現れた煩悩をコントロールしなくちゃいけない
女で始まるでしょ 女としての現れた煩悩をコントロールしなくちゃいけない
それをコントロールしたら
もう性別は超えちゃいます
因果法則 無常・無我などを発見することがブッダの瞑想実践なので
修行を上達すると心は男女の差を超えます
男女の差を超えます それでも肉体に区別があるので
戒律などは男女平等ではありません
例えば 修行して悟りに達していくと
相手が男でもない女でもないんです
もう超えているんです
聖者と言うんです では
男の悟った人がいる 女の悟った人がいる
二人とも出家している
じゃ もう男女差を消えたでしょ
超越したでしょ しかし
まだまだ体が肉体がね
男と女なんですね 物質は
だから戒律はもう差があります
女性の戒律 男性の これ変わりません
お釈迦様のお母さん パジャパティゴートに比が身が戒律の平等を頼みました
ブッダに却下されたんです
で すごいお年になってからね
パジャマティゴートにっていうのはね
お釈迦様の母親であって
お妃でしょうに お妃と言ったっても
スッドーダナ王様のはね
妃でしたし だからインドでは女性をすごく尊敬されるんですよ
家庭では年取れば取るほど
もうすごい尊敬されますね
そこで仏教では 出家した男性が女性
出家した女性が男性に礼をしなくちゃいけないんですね
だから 年取った歳歳のパジャマティーニが
まあ二十歳ぐらいの男の比丘に頭下げて礼をすると
男の人はなんか困っちゃったなとかね
なんか調子が悪くなっちゃうんでしょうね
そこを感じて もしかするとゴートミがね
これではね 若者も困るでしょうしと
ちょっと変えてちょうだいとお釈迦様に頼んだら却下
戒律は戒律よと変えれませんと
仏教にある出家習慣は
悟りに達する前からも
正式的に男女の区別をなくすことです
あの 出家っていうのは
一応男女区別をなく取り消すんですね
出家した人がもうそれから男でも女でもないんです
出家すると男でも女でもない
では 皆仲良く手を組んでごちゃ混ぜで羨ましい限りということはないんです
だって出家してれば男でも女でもないんだから
じゃあわいわいやりましょうと
これは禁止です 互いに触れることさえも禁止なんです
しかし 社会制度で守られてきた女性が出家したならば
男性の出家に女性の身を
身の安全を考える義務があります
出家したら男性たちが女性の身の安全は考えます
気をつけます しかし お互いごちゃ混ぜで生活は禁止です
同じ部屋にいることも禁止です
女性の出家に男性がいないときは説法することまで禁止なんです
しかし 出家した時点で男でも女でもないんです
厳しいといえば厳しい
出家した女性に在家でやっていたように
出家の男性を支配管理することは一切禁止
これで女性っていうのは男を管理するでしょ
出家したらお釈迦様 それは明確に禁止するんです
あんた方出家したんだから
この女の仕事をやめなさいと
だから出家した女性には
男性に向かって何も言う権利がないんです
管理禁止なんです それが何か表面的に見れば
何か男優先になっているように見えるでしょ
そうじゃないんです それが女性を消すんです
だから管理してはいけないんです
で 同時に社会では男性優先でしょ
出家したら我々に権利ないんです
例えば女の人がね 先生
私出家させてくださいと言ってもできません
権利ないんです そういう風にこの女性の自由は守ってますが
お互い管理することはもう禁じています
解脱 解脱 涅槃などについては何の区別もないんです
俗世間の次元 概念 言葉などを一切乗り越えている境地です
で 空は男女と聞けばね
あるいは中性ですかね
だから涅槃も空も同じことになってますからね
成り立ちませんね ですから
解脱との世界境地では何も存在しない
輪廻を脱出するので 生命とは言えないんです
悟りに達した人は輪廻を脱出します
だから生命ではありません
だから男も女も成り立ちません
解脱においては 区別も平等も成り立ちません
ということで 仏教の女性論男性論になります
ちょっと期待外れですね
結構難しいんです はい
これで終了です あ 後書きもありますね
知らなかった 人類は平等なのです
しかし 一人一人が違うんです
劣等感も優越感も感じる人は無知なのです
個人個人にできること
果たさなくてはいけない義務が
義務などがあります すべての生命に
また 自分にできること
自分にしかできないこともあります
生命というネットワークの中で
自分という一個が自分の役割を果たすべきです
普通はそれですよ 生き方っていうのは
生命というネットワークの中で
自分という一個が自分の義務を果たせばネットワークが守られます
その世界では男女とかね
そんなことを言っていられる場合じゃないんです
はい これで終わると思います
はい 終わります はい どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございました
それでは まず入口でお配りした質問票に書いていただいた方の質問をいくつかお持ちいただきまして
その後で会場の方で当日の講演に関して質問がある方など挙手していただいたら
何人か質問していただきたいと思います
最初の質問です  35歳の女性の方の質問です
どんな男性と結婚すれば幸せになれるんでしょうか？ あの自分に
聞こえますか？自分にどの程度で管理できるかで調べて調べてください
うまく管理できれば幸せな家庭になりますよ
それだけです はい  次 えーと
冗談じゃないんですよ
真面目です 女性はちゃんと家庭
家庭 男性をね 管理して抑えておかないと何一つうまくいかないんです
その能力は一般的には男性にないんです
ある男性もいますが ですから
これはよく真面目な答えなんです
はい  次  45歳の男性の方からの質問です
妻と 5歳になる娘がおります
妻が片付けられない人で困っております
部屋は 8 割方妻のもので占められておりますが
これが片付けられておらず
ごちゃごちゃした部屋にいるとイライラしてしまいます
かといって私が捨てて整理しようとすると怒られてしまいます
これがかなり瞑想の引っかかりになっております
アドバイスをお願いします
その場合は結構女性の方にね
不満があると思いますね
何か何かあるとは思いますね
気に入らないこととかね
これは自分のせいでもないかもしれませんしね
で 結婚する前からもね
なんか不満があった人生かもしれませんし
だからこのこういう方法で始めた方がいいんですね
自分が日曜大工みたいな感じで
日曜日はこの 例えばこの台所のこの調味料やらね
そういうものは綺麗に何か入れて
ラベル貼って何か箱を作ってあげたりとかね
綺麗にしておくとかね
米をちゃんと綺麗にして
何かにとか そういうところで整理しておくと
手を伸ばしたら取れるとかね
そういうことで どんどんこの男は整理整頓上手だなとかね
認めてくれたら まあ片付くことはまあ許す可能性はあります
で 普段は女性はね 物事をごちゃごちゃにしないんです
何でも整理するんです
それはもうハチャメチャにしているならば
何か問題があるということなんです
それはちょっと何でしょうかと調べた方がいいと思います
それに怒ったらなおさら問題がね
大きくなりますから ちょっと調べてください
はい 次ですね  29歳の男性の方ですね
いつも本を読ませていただいております
在家の仏教徒が性欲をコントロールするにはどのような方法がありますか？コツがありましたら教えてください
それは私は出家だからね
そんなのはよく知らないんですね
うん 仏教ではね やっぱり結婚していないね
他の女性とは性関係を持ってはいけないと言っているだけで
それ以上は何も言ってないんですね
女性を守らなくちゃいけないんですからね
性行為する男性が生まれてくる命に責任を持たなくちゃいけないんですよ
ですから 性行為っていうのは
仏教から見れば遊びではないんです
夫婦の性関係はなんで認めるかというと
それで二人が随分仲良くなるんですね
どんどん だから二人で生活しなくちゃいけないし
家族を作らなくちゃいけないし
子育てしなくちゃいけないし
だから二人三脚になるためにね
お互い何の秘密もないんだというふうなことのありますことがありますから
この 夫婦間の性行為には仏教は何一つも言ってないんです
だからそこはもう管理するかしないかということは
仏教の管轄ではないんです
たとえ夫婦の間で性行為を管理しているんだと思っといっても
仏教的に別に特別な道徳を守っていることにはならないんですね
女性の場合は性行為を期待しますけど
あれは欲 性欲 肉体欲よりも
女性は私を認めなさいというね
私の存在を認めなさいという気分があるんですね
だからいろいろ夫婦の話
面倒とかね 特に女性の悩みを聞いた時は
まあ男性は自分にとっては男は旦那がね
全く興味なくなったということで
かなり寂しくていうか
かなり困っているんですね
見てみると 本人が女性の方が性行為したくてたまらないかと
それでもないんですね
普通 仕事やら子育てやらで忙しいんですね
よくよく見ると やっぱりもしかすると自分のことをね
人間として 奥さんとして
自分のことはあまり無視されているんではないかという感じで心配なんですね
だからまあ それはいろいろプラス的なことがありますね
だから女性 結婚している女性の場合はね
男性と旦那との一緒になることによって
女性が自分がこの家族のね
大事な存在であると で
誰でも助けているんだと
子供たちだけじゃなくて
旦那の面倒も見てるんだという調子になるんですね
その なんて言いますか
何感っていうんですかね
えっと 役目立っているんだというね
気持ちがね 必要だと思います
はい  次は 34歳の男性の方ですね
過去に親に虐待に遭った人が
将来自分が親になった時に子供を虐待するとか
暴力を振るう男性ばかり選んで付き合ってしまう女性とか
こういうメカニズムは仏教ではどう説明されますか？ それは教育の問題だと思いますね
社会の問題なんですね
特に現代社会っていうのは
あまりにも各個人個人がすごい独立してというか
孤立しているんですね
人間には孤立して生きることはできないんです
やってはいけないんです
私はできるだけ私たちはね
みんなとなんだらかんかの関係を持ってきた方が楽なんです
何かあったら電話かけて
誰かに言うのならばね
今 最近このブログで吐き出すでしょ
あれは良くないんです
で ブログででも自分宛に話しかけてくる人がいるならば大丈夫です
自分が書いた問題に何か誰かちゃんと答えてくれるというふうにあれば大丈夫で
そうでない場合は一般的に公に晒し出すのは良くない
人間というのは親に虐待されるということは大げさな問題じゃないんです
親が子育てを放棄するとかね
いろんな問題で子供を捨ててしまうとかね
捨てられない場合はもうとにかく捨てられない場合は虐待になっちゃうんですね
そういったのは まあ生命の中で度々起こるんです
動物の中でも度々起こるんです
その時 人間の動物の場合は死んじゃいますけど
動物園だったらまあ飼育係が育ちますけど
で 人間の場合は 人間 子供が社会に育てられなくちゃいけないんですね
親が虐待する場合は おじいさん
おばあさんがよく面倒見るとかね
おじさんが面倒見るとかね
まあそういうふうに なんかどこかで自分のことを可愛がってくれることが必要なんですね
そういうやってくると
逆にはならないんですね
一人で虐待を受けただけで大きくなったら
本人には何も教育がないんですね
自分がどうすればいいかと
だから この溜まった怒りをね
どうすることもないんですね
そこはじゃあ申し訳ないんだけど
自分の国の例で説明します
自分の国でも結構あてにならない親っていうのはいるんです
で 家族に収入を持ってこない
自分が仕事 何かもう労働なんですけど
して ちょこっとちっぽけな収入をもらって
それで酒飲んじゃう で
母親がもう大変なんです
子供に食べさせるのは
それだけじゃなくて 酔っ払った旦那にも食わさなくちゃいけない
そいつはもうお金持ってこない
で  そうなってくると 子供たちには適当にご飯も食べられないし
学校に行きたいんだけど本がないとか場合は
周りは何とかしてあげるんですね
周りはたまたま今日うちでご飯食べていけないのかとかね
何のことなく言ったりするんですね
そうすると子供の気持ち悪さが消えちゃう
それで私たちよく言うのはね
お前ね だらしない父親がね
とんでもないやつやとかね
社会が父親を悪口言うんですね
で 言うと もうお前は大きくなったらね
あんなもんになったら困りますよと
で そんなこと言うと 子供たちが大きくなっても親父みたいには絶対なりませんよと
もう決まってるんですね
素晴らしくいい人間に大きくなっちゃうんですね
だから 質問にあったように
これ決まったことじゃないんですね
やっぱり社会環境の問題なんですね
人間というのは社会環境が作る作りますから
社会に問題があると思います
そういう法則ではございます
ですから 仏教的な立場は
我々は我々の子供たちが社会の財産であると
誰でも面倒見る義務があるんだと思った方がいいんじゃないかなということなんです
はい  次です  54歳の女性の方の質問です
母一人子一人で暮らすうちに
とうとううちの母も痴呆
痴呆となり 認知症となり
私が面倒を見る番になりましたが
子供の頃に精神的ないじめを受けたと思っているため
心の中では母を大事にすることができません
今は親に対して仕返しにならないよう日々気をつけてはいるのですが
内心では死んでくれたら楽になるのにと思っています
どうやって親に対しての憎しみをなくしたらよいのでしょうか？という質問です
親がこんな怒りで憎しみでね
なんとかやってるわけじゃないんですね
やっぱりそれは親が良いと思って考えてやったことなんです
皆さんもそういうことをやるでしょ
良いと思って子供にしてあげたことが逆になったとかね
それってよくありますよ
人間っていうのは失敗するに決まってますね
時々親がね 子供に苦労させた方がいいと勝手に思っちゃうんですね
苦労した方がしっかりした人間になるだろうと思って
子供があれ欲しいこれ欲しいって言っても買ってあげないとかね
金がないわけじゃないんです
こんな贅沢さえしちゃうと
こいつは悪くなるだろうとかね
それで大きくなったら父親に愛されなかったとかね
母親が厳しかったとかね
で 恨みで持っちゃっても
それは計算違いなんですね
こう理解してください
バカやと だからもう誰でも同じ人間だからね
よし 良いと良いと思ってやったことね
良いと思ってやったことが
結果としては別な結果になる
だからそれ判断ミスなんですね
だから質問の方の場合でも
お母さんが子供のことを心配したあまりにやったことが判断ミスになりました
だからまあ人間ってそんなもんやと
結局はもともとアホやということで
愛情を作った方がいいんじゃないんですかね
で まあ痴呆になってくるとね
まあ別に思考もないしね
忘れているしね 感情だけ残るしね
ですから  なんて言いますか
例えばこういうことなんですね
子供は必死で勉強する
宿題はものすごい苦労して
徹夜までして宿題をやる
しかし 先生が点数出たところで
15点とかね それに怒るべきかと
怒ったら可哀想でしょうね
徹夜してまで宿題やったのに
もう間違っちゃって 点数は 15 やと
その時をもうちょっと大きい心でね
あの子はよく頑張ったんだけど
やっぱりバカだから 15点だなとかね
いうところに優しさが必要なんですね
今の例に出てきた 今病気になりかかっているおばさまの場合でも同じことなんですね
頑張ったんだけど 点数が 15 点やと
だからそういう風に思っちゃえば
自分の母に対して慈しみというかね
心配する気持ちが生まれるんじゃないかなと思います
はい  次  32歳の女性の方です
将来を不安 不安に思わないようにしても
どうしてもこの先が不安になってしまいます
具体的にどう気をつけたらいいのでしょうか
あのね 将来は不安でいいんです
将来はいつだって不安なんです
わからないんです そこは一応ほどほどにしてください
いつだって将来っていうのはわからないものだから
気をつけるっていうことなんですね
調子に乗らないことなんですね
吾輩は安全だとかね 我が国は安全だとかね
調子に乗らない方がいいんで
例えば日本国家は 日本の憲法は世界でどこにもない類のない憲法でしょ
たった一行ですけど 戦争は放棄すると
だからって調子に乗ったらどうなるんですかね
皆様方は戦争を放棄した人間であることはちゃんとした実行してないんですね
世間にアピールしてないんです
調子に乗っちゃったんです
調子に乗ったことは 戦争する国とは何の変わりもないんです
調子に乗って凶暴になったところは
だからトラブルでしょ
だから決して安心しないことが正しいんです
日本憲法は平和憲法だからといって
我々は安心してはならんよと
我々は平和な国であることをとことんアピールしなくちゃいけないんだと
アピールして すべての人々の友情を買わなくちゃいけないんだと
それやらなかったでしょう
特に周りの国々の友情を買おうとは何の努力もしなかったんです
まあ失礼かもしれませんだけど
私の言葉は 私たちから見れば
もうすごい努力足らなかったということは見えます
そういうことで 日本が平和憲法ということで安心しちゃった
それで問題が今起きている
で 人生も同じことなんですね
将来はやっぱりあまり調子に乗らん方がいいんです
やっぱり気をつけて生活することになります
どうしても明日どうなるかということはわからないんです
だからまあ いつでもよく考えて
物事 状況を考えて判断しながら生きた方がよろしいと思います
はい  次です  56歳の男性の方です
長老は期待や希望を持つことは苦しみであるとおっしゃっていますが
その意味がよくわかりません
今日 ここに長老の話を聞きに来ているのは
苦しみの少ない人生を送りたいという私の願いを叶えてくれるだろうという期待からです
それではいけないのでしょうか
うーん  これややこしいんですね
あの 期待は 2種類あります
今質問にあるように 私の苦しみはなんとかならないのかという期待は現実的なんですね
例えば この病気はなんとかならないのかという場合は
期待が現実的なんです
病気という現実がある
苦しみという現実がある
これがなくしたい そこまでは仏教は認める
この病気治してからもうエベレストを登ってみるぞとかね
いうことがちょっと妄想ですね
例えば質問の中から見ると
私の苦しみをなくしたいと思って話
講演会に来ましたと これから苦しみをなくしてからみんなに見せてやるぞとか
私は最高 幸福なものになったんだぞとか
その期待が怖いんですね
それは妄想的なんですね
ですから 期待は現実的か妄想的かとちゃんと理解してください
妄想的期待っていうのはとんでもないんです
これはもう叶わないんです
だから期待は現実的にする
生まれてきた子供はこの子はどうやって育てるのかい？とかね
どうすれば自分のことを自分でできるようになるのかい？とかね
そういう現実的な期待は構わないんです
その期待で人間が生きているんです
数学できない子は この質問はどう答えればいいのかい？とか思うのは正しいんです
それで数学者になってやるぞと思ったら余計なんですね
数学者になる前に 自分の目の前にある宿題の数学問題を答えなさいなんですね
だから いつでも我々は現実的な問題を解決する期待は持ちます
それ以上以上はものすごく長居するんです
はい 以上です  ありがとうございます
まだ他にもいただいているんですが
他の質問をちょっと割愛させていただきたいと思います
続きまして 会場の方で質問ある方
挙手をお願いします はい
では 前列で手を挙げた女性の方お願いします
お願いします えーとですね
ずっと私の人生観において
一つの問題が起きると
それがクリアになったら
またすぐにものすごい問題が起きて
それがまあ普通の皆さんのちょっとの衝撃ぐらいのことじゃないんですよね
親も実の親じゃなかったとか
最近ですと子供を流産してしまったとか
病気になったりとか ほんと一難去っては一難
また一難で 365日気が置けないんですよ
で さっきちょっとそういうふうなお話も出てたんですけれども
そういう時にはどういうふうに考えたら楽にというか
生きてる意味を見出せるのかなと思って
まあ大体ね まあ人にはそれぞれパターンがあるんです
人生には で 面白いことがあるんですよね
そちらにはなんか人には考えられないぐらい問題が起こるとおっしゃったでしょ
でも乗り越えたでしょ
一応 ということは なんか大丈夫ということなんですね
はい 次の問題出てこいと
私はなんとかやるぞと
力があるんですね 力がない人には問題が出てこないんです
だからこの人によって自分の問題はちょっと大きく見えますけど
あれは余計な妄想ですね
自分に出てくる問題には
自分に解決できる能力もあるんです
それに合わせて問題が起こるんです
それにもまた法則があります
生きるということは 問題から問題
問題から問題で解決していく過程なんです
問題が消えちゃったら
もうどうにもならなくなっちゃうんです
生きていられなくなるんです
何もない場合はね だから問題は様々
例えば自分は育ての自分の親ではなかったとかね
それは様々ですけど よく考えてみたら
まあへっちゃらでしたと
そんなに大きいことはできなかったと
我々 人と比べてはあかんですよ
あの人はね 本当にいい親に育てられちゃって
いまだに面倒見てくれて羨ましいと
これはダメなんです それはその人の世界で
その人はいつでも親に面倒見てもくれなかったらダメな人間になっちゃうんですね
別な問題抱えてるんです
だから 各人に自分で対応できる問題が出てくる
これが大きいか小さいかとか
他人と比較する必要はないんです
これは私の問題だと これが解決する能力は私にあるんだと
実際にはあるんです ない場合は
それ以上は人生は続かないんです
だからまだ生きているということは
もう相当力があるということなんです
そういうことで あんまりそこは気にしないでください
はい 出てこいという調子になってください
はい 次の問題出てこいと
それでうまくいくと思います
はいはい うん  では 次の質問はどなたがいらっしゃいますでしょうか
次の質問出てこないんですけど
どうぞ じゃあ前列の  えーと
こんにちは 長老 あの長老のおかげで
我が家もなんかすごく落ち着いてきました
それでもう子供には関わってはいけないという気持ちになりました
そして 一つ 社会に対してのことを貢献しようかなと思って
少しやってみましたけども
一つは障害者に対してちょっと思いが違ったなと思うことで
一つ障害者をどういうふうに障害を持ってる人をどういうふうに仏教的に考えたらいいものか
なんかそこを教えていただきたいと思います
というのは障害も たちは障害手帳を持っているということで
世間にとても甘えてることを最近になってちょっと感じ取ったわけですね
それはちょっと違うかなと思って
もう障害 今男女の問題もあったけども
障害もとはそういうこと関係なしに人ということで考えた時には
障害は私たちは先か遅いかによって障害を持って死んでいくなということは自分でも自覚しているので
本当は障害手帳を持ったりとかなんとかいうところを
社会があまりにも優遇するということはもうやめて
それよりも仕事がなくて自殺をしそうな青年たちというか
若者を救った方がいいのじゃないかなと思うと
なんか今女性は強くなれというか
強い女性が社会をリードしていくもんだって
今ちょうど教えていただくと
私はやっぱりこのこれから静かに暮らそうかなと思ったけれども
本当はもっと社会に出て貢献していかなきゃいけないかなと
今講演を聞きながら 自分でそういうふうに思ったんですけども
その辺をちょっと教えてください
どの辺ですかね まあいろいろ質問たくさん入ってますけど
まあ障害者はね 手帳を持ってるんだから調子に乗るとかね
まあそういうのはあまりいいことではないかもしれませんんだけども
私たちにはそれ 個人的にどうすることもできないと思いますし
しかし それ まあそれ教えてあげたらいいんじゃないかなと思いますよ
逆にあなた方はこの過去からね
調子に乗りすぎちゃって
傲慢だったりしてね 社会に
そういうことで社会の世話になる羽目になったかもしれません
それ言ったら失礼でしょうしね
だからまあ 調子に乗ってはあかんよと
みんな同じく謙虚で生活しなくちゃいけないんでしょうにとかね
言ってもよろしいし 逆に自分が障害を持っているんだからダメだなと思った人に
だから何ですかと 私はよく言う言葉はそういうことなんですね
人々はよく 自分がこういうことで
こういうことで ちょっと普通の人とは違いますよと言った途端
私はいきなり話をカットしてね
だから何ですかと 私の答えは
人間というのはみんな障害を持ってるんだよと
私も障害を持ってるんだよと
私の方がもっとかわいそうやと
だって障害手帳はもらわないんだから
健常者とかなんとか言ってる人々も相当障害持ってますよ
ですから まあ一人一人が自分の問題は自分で解決するのは当たり前だよと
それで助けてほしい場合は助けてあげるんですよと
誰でも目が見えないんだったら
まあそれは障害なんですけど
だからといって本人が本人の人生気づかなくちゃいけないし
これで電車に乗らない場合は乗せてあげる
道路を渡らない場合は渡ってあげる
だからといって その人が人間がちゃんと手を出してくれないというふうに調子に乗っちゃったら
これまた微妙に困りますね
そこら辺は障害者という言葉が消した方がいいんですよ
障害者という言葉自体がちょっと良くないんですね
英語でハンディキャップという言葉がありますね
それは差別用語だと思って
最近フィジカルチャレンジという言葉を使うんですね
肉体的にチャレンジを受けている人々やと
まあ言葉でいろいろごまかそうとはしていますけど
それはもう 本当に我々はもうチャレンジを受けていますよ
それは肉体的な障害があろうがなかろうが
このチャレンジの世界で戦って生きているんだからね
自分の戦いをちゃんとやりなさいという話なんです
だから目が見えなくたってもね
世界一流のピアニストの若者もいるでしょうに
本人が自分のチャレンジをね
ちゃんと受けましたからね
だから目が見えないんだから
楽譜も読めないでしょうね
楽譜も読めないくせにちゃんとショパンやってますよ
しっかりと だからそこはその人のチャレンジなんですね
それで目がある人はもうピアノをやってうまくいくかというと
やっぱり目があるんだけど
楽譜も読めますが また別なところでハンディがありますね
うまくいかないとかね
そういうわけで 人類みんな障害持ってますね
みんな持ってます 我々一人一人が自分を持ってる障害をなんとかチャレンジとしてみて進む
生きてみなくちゃいけないんですね
そこで社会は障害者だという差別意識で見るんだから
社会障害手帳も出来上がったりしてね
まあ障害手帳を出すべきなのは
経済的にも障害の結果として経済的にはダメージを受けていると
場合はやっぱり何かした方がいいんですね
みんな幸せで生きていてほしいんだから
障害が障害があっても
経済的に問題ない場合はね
なんで障害手帳を出すのかと
だから障害手帳を出す場合は
これは政府のことだから
経済的に優遇するべきかないかという判断でしょ
だからそこの時点で考えた方がよかったんではないかなと思いますね
障害を持っているみんなに障害手帳を出すならば
私たちも欲しいんです
いろいろ障害があるんだから
例えば人の前で喋れなくちゃいけないんだけど
喋れないとかね 会社でいろいろ企画を頼む頼んでいるんだけど
アイディアアイディアが出てこないとかね
それって障害でしょうね
もうプロ野球選手なんですけど
スランプになっちゃって 1年も経ってるんだと
これも障害でしょうね
だから誰でも障害があるしね
学校の教師たちもね せっかく資格を取ってね
教師になったんだけど
どうもうまくいかないとかね
子供は言うこと聞いてくれないとかね
なんとか PTA というんですか
あれは怖いんだと 子供のことは怖くないんだけど
PTA の方々が来ると
もう怯えて怖くて震えるとかね
これでは仕事もうまくいかないんだと
これも障害なんですよ
先生たちには結構ありますよ
子供のことは別にどうってことないんだけど
親が怖いんですね ものすごい怖くて
もうどうしようもなくて
それで仕事もうまくいかないという
そういうわけで 誰にでも障害ありますよ
みんなで障害手帳をいただくか
経済的に問題ある方々にちゃんと経済的に優遇してあげるのかということなんですね
じゃあとにかく頑張ってください
はい それでは時間が押してますので
あと一人いける方か ではすみません
先に手を挙げた前の列の中央の方
よろしくお願いします
先ほどの期待には 2通りあって
現実的な期待というのは構わないという話だったんですが
その時にちょっと私の中で迷いが出たんですが
よく仕事なんかをやっていると
やっぱりこの先の 3年後とか 5年後の理想をしっかり描いた上で
そこに向かって努力することが大切だということが一般的にはよく言われていると思うんですが
じゃあそれは理想 理想というのはあまり良くない期待なのかなというふうなところで
ちょっと疑問というか
自分が間違っていたかもしれないなというような思いが出たので
その辺をちょっとご説明ください
間違えてる 社会はそう思っているだけの話で
現実はそれはうまくいかないんですよ
3年先考えても 例えば円高でしょうね
私も結構私にも経済状況は読めるんですけど
ここまで円高になるとは読めなかったんです
だからもうそこで円はもう 100円程度であるだろうとかね
政府も 100円程度やと
私も 100円は正当な額だと思ってますよ
で しかし みんな例えば 120
130円の 1 ドル 130円の場合は調子に乗っちゃって
5年計画を立てたところで
もう最悪状態になるでしょうね
だからこの経済でも本当は今日だけの勝負なんですよ
だからその中で 例えば車
新しい車を設計する場合は3年ぐらいかかりますけど
そこも考えた方がいいんですよ 3
年の間で何が変わるかわからないんですね
今日設計した車 3年後でマーケットに出す場合はね
うまく売れない可能性もありますよね
だから現実を見ながら考えなくちゃいけないんです
例えば この何といいますか
化石燃料を使わない車を設計するべきでしたのは
ほとんど15年 20年前なんですね
その時しっかりと研究して
研究して研究してしておいたならば
今どんどんどんどん車
次から次へと出せるでしょうに
だから偉そうに将来を見て計画を立てると言っても
やってなかったこともありますね
だから この会社などいろんなものを設計されたりする場合は
もう将来を考えますけど
当然うまくはいかないんですね
失敗はする だからいつでもこの 2つを覚えた方がいいんです
現実的な問題を見て そこに期待は大丈夫です
計画も大丈夫です 将来は起こり得るだろうという問題は起こらない可能性もあります
で 地震の場合 我々はこの安全のためにいろいろ何て言いますか
非常食とか何とかと置いておいたりするでしょうね
それで地震が起こらない場合 3
年経っても起こらない
忘れちゃいますね あの袋のこと
そこで10年経って地震が来ると
あれ一つも使えなくなっちゃうでしょ
そういうこともありますから
やっぱりその場合はもうもう賞味期限は2年だから
また全部処分して また新しいものを入れておくとかね
ことは必要になっちゃいますね
そういうことで この将来起こり得るだろうと思っていることも
なかなか起こらない場合もあるし
起こった時は準備が準備が役に立たない時もあるし
もう様々なんですね 世界のことは
私たちは特に個人の生き方について
随分個人がどうするべきかというね
ことがよく言いますから
会社で仕事を頼んだと
それ3年先考えてくださいと
それで その個人にとっては今の問題なんですね
今宿題を与えられたと
それだったら 今の問題と
その宿題に答えを出す
これがその通りになるかは誰もわからないんですね
そこら辺ですね まあ具体論なんですよ
で 民主党がね 選挙いろいろ約束して
しっかり頑張りたいという気持ちがあったんです
だからもう国民がね はいとどうそうと言ったしね
実際 政権を取ってみたところで
次から次へと予測も何もできなかった問題
考えたこともない問題
次から次へと出てくるでしょうね
で もう国にお金が全くないとかね
それで約束したものは一つも果たすことはできなくなったとかね
だから 国会の人々もいつでも過去をいじるか
くだらない妄想ばっかり喋るかだから能力は出てこないんですね
だから現実の問題にドーンとドカンとぶつかった方が大体うまくいくはずなんですよ
それをやってないように気がしますね
例えばマニフェスト マニフェストとかね
そんなことを謳ってもね
実現できない だったらね
まあマニフェストは条件そろったらやりますよと
今ちょっと待ってくれと
今はもっと大事な問題がありますよと
はっきり言った方がいいのに
言わないでしょう  そういうことでもう妄想ばっかしや仕上がっているんだからね
もう国としても困るし
会社としても困るし 国際としても困るし
だからできるだけまあ現実主義者になってほしいんですね
みんな まあとにかく希望の場合はまあ種類はあることはあります
それはどうにもならない
昔 あのね 宇宙研究を始めた時はね
将来月でも 何て言いますか
人間に住めるように何だかできるだろうと夢ばっかりいくらでも語ってるでしょ
誰も真面目に考えてないと思いますよ
あんなことできるとは
だから科学者であっても
そういうくだらない夢を描くんですね
無駄ですね 時間が 現実的な問題解決をしようとするならば
一応日々うまくいきます
はい  ありがとうございました
まだいろいろ質問あるかと思いますけど
ちょっと時間となってしまいましたので
ここで重ねさせていただきたいと思います